hello grammarians so we had said
previously that prepositions Express
relationships between two ideas right
and we can do that either in time or in
space or in other ways but today I want
to talk about prepositions in space
because this is again one of the things
that prepositions do is they can set up
relationships between objects and their
locations right so I could say the
triangle is over the square right or on
top of the square I could say the circle
is inside the square right and these are
all so over inside what I would like to
do is review some of the major ones and
and talk about what their uses are so
when we use the word at in a sentence
and here I'm talking about something we
should note is that some of these
prepositions can be used in multiple
ways right so so at has a space
connotation but it also can have a time
connotation but I don't want you to
really worry about that right now I
think it makes the most sense to just
think of their their uses as as separate
and just think of them separately so
when we talk about at as means a point
is talking about a point so we could say
something like we stood at the entrance
to a cave but he can also have this
connotation of direction as in the
creature launched itself at emina the
word by when we're talking about space
means near as in the house by the old
mill is totally haunted and all these
sentences are like really spooky not us
think of the preposition from has this
connotation of
coming from somewhere else to here as in
we came from Mars in denotes enclosed
area so you could say something like
there's a bunny in the box off denotes
you know away from she hopped off the
rock on which you know didn't usually
notes being on a surface as opposed to
in which is in an enclosed area right
like I said so we could say there's a
goblin on the front steps
right the Goblin is on the steps the
bunny is in the box you see the
difference out is another direction word
and it you know away from something at
right and off and on and in and out I
mean the opposite of each other so away
from out means away from an enclosed
area and off means away from a surface
so if you can imagine you know there's
someone who's on the rock and then they
hop off the rock there's a goblin on the
front steps
maybe the Goblin leaves the front steps
he's off the front steps there's a bunny
in the box
if the bunny leaves the box it will go
out of the box and there's plenty of
other prepositions but let's let's talk
about to which when you're talking about
to in the physical sense it has this
connotation of direction so you could
say I'm going to Mozambique these are
some of but certainly not all of the
spatial prepositions of English now
we're lucky because prepositions are a
closed group in English a closed group
we don't we don't add many of them to
the language the way that we add nouns
and adverbs and verbs and adjectives
there are a lot of them and you have to
memorize all of them and their various
obnoxious nuances but there isn't a
limitless number of prepositions there's
you know maybe a hundred plus and of
those you know maybe fifty are quite
useful and of those maybe twenty to
twenty-five are super useful and it's
the super useful most common ones that
are in the exercises so give those a go
you can learn anything Dave it out